alain bonjour merci d'être avec nous ce
matin à sur rt france alors on lisait
1,2 million et demi d'élèves à vous
retrouver les bancs de l'école
aujourd'hui quelles vont être les
premiers réflexes le premier protocole à
respecter le protocole c'est évidemment
le lavage des mains d dès l'entrée en
classe le la distanciation social entre
les entre les élèves nés s'il n'est plus
matériellement possible est plus
obligatoire donc effectivement on va se
retrouver dans des classes de nous
expliquer votre vin comme ma collègue
d'alors le dans le reportage précédent
on va se retrouver dans des classes à 30
89 39 élèves dans ma classe sans avoir
forcément la possibilité de pouvoir
respecter cette distanciation sociale
mais qui met l'état d'esprit aujourd'hui
du corps enseignant est ce que vous êtes
rassurés par les mesures en place ou au
contraire est-ce que vous êtes
complètement inquiet en fait
l'inquiétude c'est pas forcément que par
rapport aux mesures prises en place et
c'est l'inquiétude c'est le fait de se
dire temps d'entendre que on est prêt
que ça va être une rentrée une année
normale
alors qu'on pense que ça va être une
année hors norme et que manifestement à
pour la rentrée nous ne sommes pas prêts
on qu'on a pu observer dans certains
établissements en second degré qui avait
une rentrée qui pouvait être décalée en
fonction des serres que tous les élèves
ne rentreront pas aujourd'hui alors
c'est le cas aussi parfois certaines
années sauf que là c'est beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus marquée et la quiétude
c'est aussi par rapport au matériel
nécessaire pour faire cette rentrée hier
nous a distribué un petit sachet avec
cinq masques lavables bon apparemment
ils n'ont pas été distribués dans tous
les établissements il ya les
établissements du second degré dans mon
académie qui ne l'ont pas reçu encore
que les enseignants pour la rentrée
jolis noms n'ont pas encore reçu leur
masque on s'aperçoit donc le jour de la
pré-rentrée que les les auxiliaires de
vie scolaire qui accompagnés d'élèves en
situation de handicap donc pas forcément
reçu de masques et donc c'est aux
enseignants des classes de retirer un
masque du sachez qu'ils ont reçus pour
le donner
le fournir aux auxiliaires de vie
scolaire sauf que un masque c'est pas ce
n'est pas suffisant hamas parlant ce
n'est pas suffisant il faut au moins
deux masques par jour
et donc il en plus ils sont lavables
d'occupation et voilà on il faudrait au
moins une dizaine pour pouvoir tourner
de manière sereine
pareil sur l'utilisation du gel
hydroalcoolique mondiale a plus
maintenant on a des lingettes
c'est beaucoup moins voilà c'est pas
forcément adapté dont quoi il ya une
certaine inquiétude
et effectivement on s'aperçoit que non
nous ne sommes pas prêts est ce que vous
pensez qu'au quotidien justement
l'adaptation à se faire rapidement ou
alors ça va être assez long dans la
durée à l'adaptation
si vous voulez le protocole de rentrée
c'est le même protocole que que celui du
12 mai 2020 sauf qu'il a été assouplie
donc les habitudes les enseignants du
premier degré les des enseignants on
voit là ils ont eu l'occasion de
l'essayer ce protocole ce qui peut être
un peu inquiétant c'est en fait par
rapport au nombre d'élèves c'est à dire
que clairement nous n'avons pas récupéré
tous nos élèves l'an dernier un mois
j'avais 28 élèves
j'en ai jamais eu plus de 23 à partir du
22 juin la la rentrée c'est 29 et du
coup ça induit forcément beaucoup plus
de difficultés sur l'organisation dans
la classe alors le corps enseignant que
vous représentez est inquiet est ce que
vous avez eu l'occasion de rencontrer
des parents d'élèves dans quel état
d'esprit
se trouve t-il aussi oui j'ai eu
l'occasion d'en croiser et puis moi même
je suis je suis parent d'élève donc
effectivement le questionnement il y à
peu près noble c'est à dire que
l'inquiétude que nous on a pour pour nos
élèves
je pense que les parents doivent se
poser même type de questions pour leurs
enfants
alors il nous confie ce qu'ils ont plus
cher et le plus précieux et forcément il
voudrait que ce soit le plus serein
possible qu'il n'ait pas à se poser de
questions et d'inquiétudes
elle est marquée alors sur pas forcément
sûr qu'il a des chances d'être des
masques dont premier degré parce que ça
c'était assez clair mais sur voilà sur
la distanciation social sur la limite du
brassage sur ace combat faire classe
comme avant non c'est ce ne sera pas
possible on a vu tout à l'heure des
professeurs manifester du côté de melun
hier est ce que
vous comprenez ces professeurs qui
manifestent et est ce que on peut
s'attendre à peut-être d'autres
manifestations de ce genre dans l'est
dans les jours à venir
le snuipp fsu avait demandé il ya
quelques jours le report de la rentrée
pour les enseignants en histoire d'avoir
le temps de mettre en place le protocole
et faire une rentrée sereine avec le
matériel qu'il fallait et sans avoir
toutes les questions qu'on se pose de
demain on sait pas le cas mais donc du
coup les enseignants ils seront ils sont
en classe tout à l'heure il était là
prêt ont rejoint les prêts entrés ils
étaient dans les écoles hier est ce
qu'il y aura des manifestations jeu
c'est possible mais nous n'avons pas a
priori à la gamme de façon nationale
pour pour les jours qui viennent
maintenant voilà peut-être le
ponctuellement dans certains
établissements en fonction de la
situation m notamment matériels en terme
de deux organisations se précise merci
beaucoup à l'internaute d'avoir été avec
nous ce matin sur rtl rappelle et que
vous êtes professeur des écoles et co
secrétaire du snuipp fsu du nord merci
beaucoup fois